Let's take a look at this identity right here. We have log base a of AB is
equal to log base a of A plus log base a of B. Now, is this true in general for
any base a? And indeed, it is. The formal name of this, is the product
property. And since we know this is a property of logs in general, logs of any
base, we know that it is true for the natural logarithm as well. Put simply,
the log of a product is the sum of the logs of the numbers that were multiplied
to make that product. Let's use this rule, but in reverse to find log base 10
of 2 plus log base 10 of 5. First, simplify this into the log of one number,
and then tell me what that's equal to. Please try this without a calculator
first, but definitely feel free to check it to make sure it, that it works with
your calculator.